hi I'm Decker Montgomery and I'm going
undercover on the Internet this is
actually seriously it's actually me
first up Twitter MacMurray pants says
how many times a day do you watch naked
Montgomerys audition for stranger things
I haven't watched it I've seen various
clips when we've been doing press and
stuff but I haven't really watched it
there's a lot of other ones there that
are on private on my VM EO account that
I wouldn't want to see the light of day
my mother after seeing Decker
Montgomery's abs in Power Rangers are
those drawn on no they're not I spent a
long time training before I came to
Canada to shoot the film but I can tell
you that they're only like that during
shooting and I smash out about another
20 pounds on as soon as we wrap just
smashing I don't drink I don't smoke so
it's like that's my vice I guess right I
saw Decker Montgomery's doppelganger
working at New York fries today or was
it actually taken and he decided acting
wasn't working out are you okay buddy
how's it going can I get a veggie it
works all the New York fried fries
references just went over my head I'm
sorry because I'm not from here but I
will say that you never know how long
you were gonna have what you have and I
am prepared to go back to being a
barista next year I'm always prepared I
did it for many years and I'm just lucky
to be having an opportunity right now to
to do something I love is the Shrek make
you know how many times a day I get this
so deca Montgomery as Shrek in a
live-action like the human Shrek yeah
look I'm down for it I just don't know
if I would do justice to Shrek wait
who's the voice Mike Meyers who's the
voice of Shrek I bet then I as well I'm
like I can't compete with my clients
it's Mike lies I'm not gonna do that
yeah I know I'm not gonna do that take
Montgomery as Raider hood slash Jason
Todd he would perfectly bring
evil acting the character has shown in
strange things I don't know I feel like
I'm at it I I'm at an interesting point
where I'm enjoying seeing the universe
has come to an end and how the ones
begin but I would really love to play
outside of the world that's so prominent
I guess in cinemas at the moment which
is just origin stories of amazing
superheroes that we love I'd love to
dive into a different world that we
don't know that we aren't kind of given
a lot of both in television format and
cinema superheroes growing up I don't
know I didn't have anything in
particular you know I remember as a kid
I had all the action figures like he-man
and that blue guy from x-men the wolf
guy forget his name Nicholas Hoult yeah
beast but I didn't really have any
specific I was more kind of interested
in like interior design and kidding out
my room and sister this strange kid
about two years ago I went and did an
interior design internship in a shooting
break in LA which was amazing and it
kind of opened my eyes up to this whole
other world of sourcing fabric figuring
things out and figuring out how spaces
would work and I'm really interested in
lighting and how that affects our mood I
want to get to Kanye on everyone here
but I I definitely think it has a big
impact on us and yeah Instagram how
underscore very says any chance the mind
flayer stabbing Billy through the chest
four times like didn't kill him ask for
a friend I keep saying this it's like
obviously the portal I guess to the
upside down is closing at the same time
so you think all because that's being
cut off that's why the monsters dying
but in our discussions that was partly
it because Billy is the predominant host
for that creature in killing him or in
stabbing him as how various talking
about here it does kill itself which I'm
assuming is that what they mean and you
don't have to ask for a friend you can
just ask me so main Queen Bane says what
is this yes that's a good question so I
have a podcast that I'm doing which
comes out in two days holy [ __ ] let's
just say my advertising campaign to
promote it
been a little bit not off brand but I
think confusing for most people I
started collating my beep poetry about
10 months ago that I've been writing for
the last few years and I built it into
six tracks and then I reached out to
musicians all around the world to
compose scores and I now write my poetry
so I'm very nervous it's very personal
it's very close to me I'm kind of
excited for everyone to just hear what
this is and hear what it's about the D
km/h podcast comes out July 11th on all
platforms Decca Montgomery how would you
feel about a second Power Rangers movie
if possible that's a really good
question my biggest thing is I learned a
ton on that movie so I would be happy to
jump back into it and secondly that cast
is like my family and we've all gone on
to have amazing opportunities so I'd
love to reunite with everyone but I
don't think it's gonna happen I'm sorry
YouTube why is his American accent
better than mine and I'm American that's
very flattering but I spent a lot of
time working on my accent one thing that
I did learn going through is that the
Americans have I guess what's called a
rhotic ah so like as opposed to we
wouldn't pronounce the R in most things
like part part of and Americans would go
heavier on the are like part I think as
any actor or anything so you sort of
still hear flaws subtle floors there's
one point in season three that I still
cringe at when I'm watching there's a
moment in the scene in the sauna when I
smashed through the window and I'm
yelling at my younger sister max and I
think someone at one of the only times
that there's just like a expletive in
the show and it was so Australia so
Australian IMDB is very good
we'd be doing parkour on my high school
roof we'd get in trouble but I was never
a reckless kid it's kind of a oxymoron
there it's because it sounds like I'm a
reckless very reckless yeah we did a lot
of jumping around the school ruse with
client I the amount of times I should
have broken my legs and it never
happened but ya know I was a hugely
adventurous kid and even though school
was tough for me I always found kind of
ways to kind of climb around things I
was that kid that would do enough that
I'm not gonna like crush my genitals on
a pole or like yeah so based some of my
performances as Billy in stranger things
on my own experiences being bullied in
school yes I certainly did I was bullied
pretty badly in school I was so a really
big kid and but I think more so than
anything would have been talking to his
is finding empathy for the bully because
we all have insecurities it wasn't just
me and as I always say I got to go home
to a really good family environment and
I'm sure most of the people that who
were antagonizing me didn't so yeah I'm
descended from Charles the second of
England who was king of England Scotland
and Ireland from 1662 1685 and King of
Scotland from 1649 to 61 this descent is
through Charles's daughter and Leonard
Countess of Sussex actors Kit Harington
and Rose Leslie are also descended from
Johnson City yep that's all correct my
mum's family are the Barrett Leonard's
so if you see here Charles's daughter
and Leonard I'm assuming that's the
connection but I think my name was
originally Celtic and then French and
there's sort of different derivatives I
guess like that yeah more Twitter so
much Twitter a goose named Keith says
how does one pronounce taker of day to
Montgomery so in Australia this is
getting back to the Rohtak are that are
speaking about before so des car is just
a car like five acres to the next farm
right let's say the unit of measurement
acre
so we say echo and in America generally
I'm sure I'm wrong in pots but people
say acre so dico would be de coeur so
that's just the translation and then
Montgomery is the most standard name you
can have so it's a nice couple iconic
spider-man says they come on gamma-ray
my Australian man can you please drop
that skincare routine thanks in advance
look I don't know I really have a
skincare routine I would just say that
my parents always told me don't get too
much Sun and yoga is good hot yoga just
sweat it out and you will be glowing
like the in-between of my eyebrows is
glowing like a bowling ball the fact
that the loml deck of Montgomery is from
Australia just amazes me I mean which
part of Australia is he forgetting is
there our city of hot men here where day
care Brenton Thwaites and the Hemsworth
brothers are from love it well the the
Hemsworth brothers are from one of the
most beautiful places in Australia which
is Byron Bay it's just south of the Gold
Coast and I have friends from there we
go out hang out there a lot scourged by
the world but I am from Perth which is
on the west coast it's one of the most
isolated capital cities on the planet
and it's absolutely beautiful
fudge cat says can you think of a name
more elegant than Daegu Montgomery or
I'm sure there are many many names more
elegant than Dec Montgomery and I will
not claim to have the most elegant one
fudge cats are great now I'm down for it
well
ah that is it I guess I my sign-off
thank you